This throwback sitcom sequel is keeping one
controversial element from the original.
To some fans, there's nothing funny
about bringing back this sitcom trope.
Originally created in the 1940s, the laugh track
was first made to help bring an artificial "at
the theater" experience for radio listeners at
home. When TV began to take off in the '50s,
it was used to enhance the actual laughs that came
from a live studio audience. And it worked, too. A
study from the University College London confirmed
that hearing background laughter, such as the
chuckles from a pre-recorded laugh track, trick
the brain into thinking bad jokes are funnier.
"Haha, that's actually hilarious."
However, towards the end of the
'90s/early 2000s, popular shows like
"The Larry Sanders Show," "Malcolm in the Middle",
"Arrested Development" and others proved
that fans no longer needed their hands
held when it came to knowing when to laugh.
Now, in the current television landscape,
laugh tracks can come off as antiquated. While
the artistic choice isn't as popular these days,
Netflix's new "That '90s Show" series brings
the laugh track back with a vengeance.
The streaming giant recently debuted
the 10-episode first season of "That
'90s Show." For those who don't know, it's
linked to the original "That '70s Show,"
with many of the same characters/actors
popping up in this latest installment.
However, returning actors aren't the only holdover
that fans might recognize from the original. The
laugh track is back, and based on comments
on social media following the show's release,
some viewers are not happy with
this artificial audience reaction.
"It's a normal temperature, Eric. You've
just got that sensitive baby skin."
Whether it was to enhance live audience reactions
due to poor microphones back in the day or to
replace audiences altogether, the laugh track
has been around for a long time. With plenty
of early '90s sitcoms continuing the trend,
it seems like it would be a smart choice to
have Netflix's new series, "That '90s Show,"
use the same background enhancement. However,
it's clear that there are plenty of viewers
out there who no longer accept this tactic.
One Twitter user didn't seem
happy with it at all, commenting,
Another declared,
Viewers over on Reddit were also not too
fond of this throwback tactic. One wrote,
Another wrote,
"I don't know how the whole puberty
thing is going for you. Probably great."
Despite the negativity, there
were some users who totally
understood the reasoning for using
the audio, with commenter writing,
Other users echoed a similar
sentiment, with one saying,
As it turns out, just like its predecessor,
"That '90s Show" was shot in front of
a live studio audience in Hollywood.
While the laughs are authentic, so is
the use of a laugh track. Laugh tracks
continued to be popular among viewers until
the 2000s. With the sitcom set in the '90s,
it would arguably be inauthentic
to debut the series without some
background chuckling. At least, that's
what some fans think. One fan offered,
"Really?"
"That '90s Show" isn't the only modern legacy
sequel/reboot that utilizes a laugh track.
Consider Hulu's "How I Met Your Father," the
spinoff sequel series to CBS' fan-favorite
"How I Met Your Mother." Just like "That '90s
Show," "How I Met Your Father" was criticized
for utilizing a laugh track, with many dubbing
its use corny and antiquated. For "How I Met Your
Father" co-showrunner Isaac Aptaker, however,
bringing the laugh track back was necessary,
as it continued the same vibe as the original.
The same can be said for "That '90s Show."